uh let's just go ahead and address this
mess real quick because you guys all
have questions and I have answers and
you stereotypes fact the fiction Oh
[Music]
what's going on YouTube it seems that
everybody wants to know about Asian
people nowadays and I don't understand
what the fascination is people are begin
to treat us like we're like we're like
we're trading cards or some [ __ ] yo
homie I'll trade you my Korean for that
Laotian so I'm here to save you from
walking around asking stupid questions
and getting your ass whooped by a bunch
of ninjas is it true that Asian guys
have a small Shiva tank tanks up next
question
Asian people are so cheap let me tell
you something Asian people are not cheap
we just don't want to pay full price you
know that we made I want to say we're
cheaper say we're more like hustlers
babe you know I'm very we just get
discounts on everything because we know
how to work people like what go into a
store I complained about something on a
product that's supposed to be there
excuse me I prepared a full price for
these pens they have two holes in it sir
those are called pockets sure yeah no oh
God Asian people have such bad drives
but you know I used to get so pissed
when people told me that Asian people
can't drive until I got my license and
that [ __ ] is true the thing is we're
either really bad drivers over really
good you know I eat fast and furious
here's an interesting fact for you you
could look the [ __ ] up on Wikipedia
where is the most dangerous place to
drive on earth an Asian supermarket a
bunch of Asian people trying to figure
out how to park into minivans and then
90-95 you know red Toyota pickup trucks
look up your fianc if you see a car in
the road with his blinker on for about
15 minutes
it's either an Asian person or an old
person or both engines are so good at
math of course we're good at math okay
especially the ones outside the states
that even better but the thing is
anybody generally with a decent
education outside the US has better
education in math and you know we
Americans do because I suck at math
myself someone stead of bagging on the
Asian that barely speaks English wants
to go in and just be his friend you know
copy up his homework I did
Asian girls are so submissive
[ __ ] you have been watching way too
much anime for you to be thinking that
have you met my mom she is a scary-ass
woman to all those pervy guys out there
they have mail-order brides from Asia
because you think they're submissive
just wait till they come to America and
learn their favorite word
no that's right then they learned their
favorite three word phrase oh oh go to
hell then watch when the English gets
bigger this time mixing it up a little
bit Hey no don't touch me dammit [ __ ]
go to him
Asian people stink [ __ ] your thing all
nail salons beauty supplies and lots of
Medicine all my Asian people yeah that's
right oh all Asians look alive it's not
true but let's be honest for a second
people but why people say that you
shouldn't get mad because you know we
honestly can't expect them to tell the
difference yeah I mean because I can't
even tell why people partner for example
hey Rob
what's it like to be white man I'm not
white buddy I'm a little Irish a little
bit of Scottish with a little smidgen of
French biak said you're three different
flavors of vanilla how the I supposed to
know Indians are not Asians what
continent do you think India is from
[ __ ] Asian people are so racist and all
yeah but racist but at the same time
well not because we hate all races
equally we're just a culture / race for
the heinous is in our blood we can't
help it
Korean people especially because we're
cell races we have a North and South
Korea we don't like all people hate
sensation 30 Korean captain second
duration full you're Korean I know but
use a dirty clear if there are any more
questions about Asian people go ahead
and ask away and I'll be more than happy
to answer to all you people out there
change ha I'm sorry that's not funny
whatever happened or
[Music]
hold on a goddamn second